[Musique]
si sakho devant la cuillère magento
d'entente là
[Musique]
sinon il est atteint alors que ça
débloque
c'est pas juste pickas et très savoureux
mon avis la vague au juste aller en
montant et non et non le contraire
le marché des sauces piquantes atteint
2,7 milliards de dollars à l'échelle
mondiale en 2021 et les sauces piquantes
fabriqués au québec ne sont pas en reste
il en existe maintenant plus d'une
centaine sur le marché
des produits
géniaux d'arles qui le plein depuis
l'aube auditeurs du québec ma mère
ou sur nos les sources d'un trait pussin
propriétaire de la boucherie beaubien
depuis 20 ans daniel malouf collectionne
et offre une sélection impressionnante
de sauce piquante fermenté ou non et les
sauces québécoise ne cesse de prendre de
l'espace sur ses tablettes de la
tendance de valérie bègue dormir année
acheter la casse sur le medac sort
beaucoup beaucoup
julien fréchette cinéaste de métier est
tellement passionné par le piment et les
sauces piquantes qu'il a décidé d'en
faire un documentaire j'ai toujours été
fasciné par le piment et de fonder une
compagnie l'api menteries je pense
qu'avec vague en fait qui était déjà en
prime de déferler sur l'amérique du nord
au grand complet et puis le québec il
fait pas exception je considère un peu
le marché d'assaut scar un peu comme le
marché de la micro brasserie une dizaine
d'années on est là où ce que des micros
princier tales and année donc il ya un
engouement on a discuté et bornés
malheureusement on n'ira pas avec votre
propulsé par des missions dans l'est du
dragon en 2010 cette faille au bounce
compte aujourd'hui une vingtaine
d'employés ont trouvé qu'ils avaient pas
beaucoup d'offres de sauce carte au
québec et on a décidé de créer des
choses qui sont non seulement que
piquants sont extrêmement sawers
[Musique]
la compagnie phare banque établie à
saint nicolas s'est associé au jardin
claude et louisa qui cultivent du piment
en montérégie donc les chats gonna
derrière vous c'est pour vos sauces
seulement quand on regarde ce qu'on fait
c'est extra c'est vraiment tout pour
nous autres je pense que ces deux temps
complète qui est qu'est la firme utilise
pour faire pousser nos récoltes de
piment
il ya trois ans et demi ont marqué de
piment fort pour faire noter ses achats
et franck monnet s'est pas de bon sens
il doit avoir certainement des
producteurs québécois qui font du piment
fort alors on est parti et on sert à
manger ici à ces dames ans maintenant on
récolte près de 150 tonnes de piment ici
les abonnés rôle et je rappe et non les
poivrons rouges verts ils viennent et
bientôt du sud à proximité la fraîcheur
tout ça c'est sûr que les produits sont
plus frais sont cultivés ici arrive le
lendemain notre usine sombre assis
dessus et vous senti l'engouement des
québécois pour avoir un produit local a
définitivement mais c'est un engouement
des québécois pour le pique un point
après ceci peut être ainsi peut être
local donc les sauvegardes c'est encore
mieux
[Musique]
mais en fait tous les piments qu'on voit
ici viennent de moins 50 km il y avait
les producteurs qui sont un champ en
fait ici aussi en périphérie de montréal
qui a passionné des piments qui sont en
serre qui me fournit donc une bonne
partie de piment qui sont un peu plus
durs à trouver qui sont pas normalement
sur les marchés internationaux si on
revient déjà vingt ans en arrière il y
avait peut-être pas la moitié en faire
deux de ses variétés là et maintenant on
a vraiment l'éventail des piments qu'on
trouve presque à travers le monde ici au
québec donc l'idée c'est juste de faire
des partenariats avec des producteurs
locaux
est-ce qu'on a une identité au québec
avec nos sauces piquantes et c'est
l'innovation c'est là la multitude des
goûts des assemblages c'est vraiment ça
nous qui nous a caractérisés passé c'est
facile de faire une source clients dans
la mesure où disons tabasco le fait
depuis presque deux cents ans
l'ingrédient s'est vivement du vinaigre
du sel ça c'est la barre dont une source
cliente après ça nous ce qu'on aime a
ajouté ben c'est l'aspect l'aspect
gourmets c'est l'aspect ça va il faut
que ça goûte bon
sirop d'érable pomme bières et saveurs
ajouté sont aussi des valeurs ajoutées
qui augmente le prix ces explosions de
goût en bouteille coûte entre 8 et 13
dollars
nos employés sont ici notre usine est de
6 donc 100% effet ici est cultivé ici ça
ça fait de nous une compagnie 100 %
local
100% le calme à quel point quand on
ajoute parfois de la nana du citron de
la pulpe d'orange
pasteurisation habanero qu'il allait se
sont pas mal de fil à 100% qu'il boit
mais boulimie viennent d'où
julie mm au 10 mai ouais c'est avec
anima québec il ya 80 et 90 pour ça
qu'il doit être faite ici au québec et
nous on respecte vraiment 90 pour ça et
je laime versus 250 litres sérieux dans
une cacophonie batch et aliments québec
celle qui est certifié québec c'est la
cerise à 100% les autres préparés au
québec est ce que le nerf de la guerre
ça va être de se démarquer dans toute
l'offre québécoise avec des produits
québécois
je crois que de la place pour tout le
monde la compétition c'est 5 donc il
sait conservateur qui vont mobiliser des
gens sont très curieux je ne pense pas
que c'est une bonne parce que c'est
vraiment un goût qui une fois keita qui
y demeurent
la table est mise
mangeant
[Musique]